أيضًا ، ربما يجب أن أقول إن
مقابلته مثل أم
، الأمر مختلف ، ليس عليك أن
تسرق نفسك حقًا
لرد الفعل المحتمل آه عندما
تطرح مواضيع غير مريحة مثل
عندما سألت نائب الرئيس المنتخب هاريس
عن شيء قالته  هذا
يتناقض مع
الرئيس أه المنتخب بيدن عندما سألت
الرئيس بايدن عن
إخوته وابنه ،
لقد سألت عن عائلته كان
أحد أفراد عائلته
سيكون في أي مجالس أو أي وظائف
قد تكون في صراع نعم الصياد بايدن
أحضر صياد
الصياد وأعذرني أيها الصياد وليس البابا لكنك
قمت بتربيته ولم يكن هناك
لحظة جديرة بالاحباط
أجاب عليها بوضوح شديد
وبوضوح أجاب على السؤال
نعم لن يفعل أحد أي شيء
من حيث الصفقات التجارية أه هذا
سنخلق مظهرًا
غير لائق مرة أخرى ، سنرى ما سيحدث ،
لكن
لم يكن
هناك هجوم تعرفه كما هو الحال
في المنطقة الرابعة  لقد
اعتدنا على أه ، لذا كان هذا مظهرًا غير عادي ،
لديه الكثير من الطموحات والآمال
وهو متفائل جدًا ، أعني أنه
يقر بأن الأمر سيكون صعبًا ،
لكنه متفائل بشأن قدرته
على إنجاز شيء ما
مع مجلس الشيوخ.  لقد اعترفت ،
قلت إنك تعتقد أن الحمى التي قال
إنها ستكون مختلفة بعد تصويت الناخبين ،
قلت إنك تعتقد أن
الحمى ستنهار من حيث حقيقة أن
العديد من أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الجمهوريين لم يعترفوا حتى
بالواقع الأساسي
بأنه  الرئيس
المنتخب وقال إنها ستفعل مع القيادة الجمهورية ،
لا أعرف شيئًا عن الجميع ،
لذلك كان هذا بمثابة
اعتراف وحتى البعض اتصل
به وهنأه لكنهم
كثيرون لن يفعلوا ذلك